[Music]
we love watching the Harry Potter movies
over and over but have you ever noticed
how weird some of the scenes are we've
got 10 of the creepiest scenes in Harry
Potter that need to be addressed keep
watching to find out who the creepiest
character of all time is Draco Malfoy
really caused a problem in Prisoner of
Azkaban when he claimed that Buckbeak
and injured him first of all he was
barely hurt and second of all he
completely ignored Hagrid's instructions
but thanks to Lucius Malfoy pull at the
Ministry Buckbeak got a sentence of
capital punishment poor Hagrid tried his
hardest to appeal the case even had
Hermione's help but when the day came
for Buckbeak to meet his end the
Minister for magic showed up with an
executioner this guy was so creepy he
was like a medieval executioner
we know the Wizarding World can be a
little stuck in the past but did he
really need to be wearing a full leather
hooded mask and did this guy's full-time
job
revolve around executing animals cuz
that's messed up why does the ministry
need someone like that on staff plus he
was planning to use an axe on buck beaks
neck but their wizards there has to have
been a more humane way to carry out the
ultimate punishment even Avada Kedavra
would have been more humane the whole
executioner thing just seems
unnecessarily creepy excuse me your
services are no longer required
okay we have to admit of all the
fantastic beasts in Harry Potter best
rules are the creepiest they're kind of
like horses but they don't look all
together alive they're all bony and they
don't have hair when harry sees them for
the first time in order of the Phoenix
he is understandably freaked out to make
matters worse no one else except Lunas
sees them his friends think he's crazy
later Luna explains they can only be
seen by people who've seen death isn't
that creepy we have to wonder what JK
Rowling was thinking when she came up
with that but the thestrals present a
huge plot hole - Harry can now see them
because Cedric Diggory fell to an Avada
Kedavra earlier that year but harry has
seen other people go before that as a
baby he watched a Voldemort cast the
same spell on his mother he remembers
that enough to hear her screams when the
Dementors are closed and he watched
quarrel meet his end in The Sorcerer's
Stone so why is he now just seeing the
festro's we fly of course snakes are a
very real phobia for millions of people
so Chamber of Secrets is extra creepy
for those who are scared of slithering
beasts the basilisk is a huge magical
snake Salazar Slytherin put it in the
deepest parts of the school when he
built his chamber of secrets seriously
why was that guy allowed to be around
kids in start a school when the chamber
is open the basilisk starts moving
through the school through the pipes and
attacking the people its gaze can
petrify muggle-borns or worse wait a
second look how huge that thing is just
how bigger the pipes at this school
anyway
here he goes into the chamber to save
Ginny yes papa
the process is nearly complete in a few
minutes Ginny Weasley will be dead and
he meets the basilisk this giant snake
which has venom in its fangs bites a 12
year old boy one of its fangs literally
comes out in Harry's arm this movie was
rated PG that seems extra graphic and
creepy plus there's another plot hole in
the later movies we find out that
basilisk venom can kill a Horcrux why
didn't that bite kill the Horcrux that
was inside Harry
it's over or Remus Lupin he was one of
the saddest stories in all of Harry
Potter he was bitten by a werewolf as a
young boy becoming a werewolf every
month makes him feel ill for days there
are so many anti werewolf laws that he
has a hard time finding a job
he's so discriminated against then he
loses all of his best friends as a young
man plus he has no control over the
beast that he becomes and Lupin is one
of the kindest men in the entire series
eat you'll feel better in Prisoner of
Azkaban the hunt for Sirius Black
distracts him from the full moon he
forgets to take the Wolfsbane potion
which would calm his inner wolf and then
he starts to turn in front of Harry and
the others the transformation is extra
freaky it looks so painful when his body
contorts but can we talk about what the
werewolf looks like does that look like
any wolf you've ever seen he's a creepy
half-man half-beast thing why do his
arms and legs look so human it's really
bizarre and don't take any details if
you do know the basilisk isn't the only
creepy thing in Chamber of Secrets
everything about Gilderoy Lockhart made
us really uncomfortable we want to know
exactly what Dumbledore was thinking
when he hired him to be the Defense
Against the Dark Arts teacher Lockhart
is so full of himself that he makes
Draco Malfoy seem humble we realized
just how arrogant he is when Harry meets
him at the bookstore with my entire
collected works free of charge
then Lockhart proves really quickly that
he is completely incompetent that is
subject he can't even take care of
Cornish Pixies he gets extra creepy when
he makes here he helped him sign fan
mail how is that remotely appropriate
for a student Lockhart just gives off
such a creeper vibe we could have
forgiven him if he was just dumb and
arrogant but he was malicious too he
wipes people's memories and takes credit
for their actions you first mr. puffer
say goodbye
to your memories he planned to obliviate
Harry and Ron who were just kids we are
so glad that spell rebounded causing
lockhart to lose his memory who are you
who can forget the mountain troll from
The Sorcerer's Stone this scene was
crucial because that's when Hermione
became friends with Ron and Harry
Hermione had run off to the bathroom
crying after Ron insulted her at dinner
chloral announced to that there was a of
course he was the one who led it in Ron
and Harry ran after Hermione and saved
her from the troll but let's take a look
at this troll this thing had giant warts
all over his feet and legs his gross
belly hung over his pants and just look
at that bass he was so creepy
honestly we think Hermione handled
seeing this creature pretty well she
didn't even scream till he knocked down
the bathroom stall but then the scene
got disgusting
Harry stuck his wand up the trolls nose
once Ron knocks the troll out Harry
pulls out his wand and it's covered in
troll snot that was completely
unnecessary
we hope you weren't eating when you
watch that scene who was the creepiest
person in the whole series keep watching
to find out
this next scene is also from The
Sorcerer's Stone quarrel is really a
strange character throughout the whole
movie oh nice to meet you faithfully
fascinating subject when Harry makes it
to the mirror of Erised say to get the
Sorcerer's Stone we find out why the
defense professor is so weird
he has Baltimore living on the back of
his head talk about creepy okay we get
that Baltimore soul didn't have a body
to live in so he more or less possessed
Quirrell but was having a space on the
back of the poor guy's head really
necessary this was such a bizarre scene
and it was kind of terrifying now we
just have questions did quarrel have
hair before Voldemort space popped up
Howard involved the Mort space feel
about showering and did it hurt when
quarrel laid down on his head honestly
it's kind of hilarious to think about
those things but it sure was a strange
way to bring Baltimore back Paul d'amour
isn't just evil he is a total creep and
one extended scene showed exactly how
strange he is often times the movies
take out some of the best scenes from
the books this is true with any
franchise but every now and then the
movies at a priceless moment this scene
was from the extended cut that was
released on DVD when everyone thinks
Harry has fallen victim to the avada
kedavra curse Voldemort and the Death
Eaters come back to Hogwarts
he calls Draco back over to his side
and praises him Draco did not want to go
back to the evil side but to make
matters worse Voldemort decides to hug
him why it's so out of character for him
he is not a warm and cuddly villain at
all and the hug will make you cringe
it's clear Voldemort has no clue what
he's doing and we can feel Draco's
discomfort through the screen we aren't
quite sure what the directors were
trying to accomplish here but it sure
was creepy and who might you be unmad ah
mad-eye moody this paranoid or or was
meant to be a creepy character and one
thing that made him extra weird was his
eye he had lost an eye in some sort of
fight with a dark wizard so he replaced
it with a magical eye it could see all
around him and it constantly turned
around and around but that's not even
the freakiest part of his eye minister
says you're too young to see what these
courses do different that honor belongs
to Dolores Umbridge now Umbridge is
definitely a creep in her own right the
collection of cat plaits is more than a
little unsettling but somehow after
moody is taken out by Death Eaters she
gets her hands on his magical eye she
doesn't wear it though she puts it on
her office door it's freaky and it's
really disrespectful but this woman is
something else she wants to keep an eye
on all the people working for her
literally that scene really took the
creepy factor up a notch Umbridge is the
worst
I really hate children we know that Bal
de mort is a total creep it's part of
his whole villain vibe but you know who
is even creepier than Lord Voldemort
young Tom Riddle honestly we expect to
feel unsettled when we see Voldemort
he's got no nose after all the
creepiness is even worse when he's just
a boy when Dumbledore goes to meet Tom
Riddle in the orphanage we get chills
every time he's got the horror movie
stared down to an art and then he goes
on to tell Dumbledore that he can make
people hurt if he wants to
and it's clear that he enjoys doing it
Dumbledore should never have taken him
to Hogwarts
Tom also has a picture on the wall of
some cliffs in the seat it's the same
place Harry and Dumbledore go to find a
Horcrux it's not addressed in the movies
but in the books the head of the
orphanage revealed why it's significant
Tom had lured some orphans there on
holiday it's not clear what he did to
them but they were never the same again
and you say creepy which scene from the
Harry Potter series gives you the chills
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching for more fun videos from the
things be sure to LIKE and subscribe
we'll see you next time